ええええええ
20分
ああああああ
はい恥ずかしい理解しません
のままん
時給が上がっています
カラーん
人生お話
ビジネスを指導
コラボがないのに
時給がわかっていると思った
強い時期じゃないと思う
知ってい
バランスがとれないん
よ馬鹿じゃないの
強いといけないとうま鍋
車が入っています
今日は駒の哲学についてい
私はベンチャーリーオーの人生の責任者
英語での会社の責任者
この子の人生な責任者
今まで一番いいよの人たちの面接をしてみません
そこで本画質のおきましょうん
あなたの質問
あなたのミッションは何ですか
企業ミッションと個人の力のか
どうまずん
考えてると思っ
ただ多くの人たちは私たちを期待
その味噌が私たちます
インドで礼節を知るということです
あっている候補者はこう言うでしょう
2030年
80万人日本で市にあるとか
解決しないん
ただ多くの高い車
今や給料が多数
ああああああ
薔薇もええ
彼らは給料が出せればいい
とうございました
私はいい
キョンが真にわー
彼らは
まずの欲求にも耐えています
私は航行の安全な時代でも作れるん
息子がわかるしてね
ただインドではまだ
カースト制度が薬学昇
エンジニアであっても
月収10
お送ります
変更層がをいるんです
まず本人を出しない
20代前半の時
スティーブジョブズが素晴らしい腫瘍やんだい
時より素晴らしい愛会が開き
メンダーオーナーサンん
ありがとうございます
この間カバー
すごくわかると思うんですよね
私も見てもらえない
そして
使いからおもちゃのコマを
しました
栄養 i 君
こまな俺
コマ
軸がないとうまくん
ページです
私は周りからの評価ばかり口にしなんです
お金持ちになりたい
社会が強化されたい
あげたまえでした
私は幸せではなりません
そしてインタビューを受けたりとかです
間違った質問を教えたことに消せます
味なんです
誰もが私と同じ軸を持っていると
とんでもないん
それはどれだけ自分の軸が良かったけど
ではん
たった一つ星
らしい質問ある
[音楽]
このコマわー
他に回すことができます
それはー
個人の幸せです
世界中を旅行したい
らへんのか欲しい
映画わー
留学ん
ありません
私は
留学します
なぜ留学をしたかと聞かれたらん
グローバルな世界で働かないかな
思っていさ
4年生になって
就活が始まり社会人になっています
毎日同じ日々を過ごすことがイヤっ
自由になりたかった
過去に入って毎日
サーフィンをしました
体にあるのサーフィンライブ
私は
私たちは何が私たちを幸せにするか考えることがあります
discover 呼ばれる
あなたの価値を発見
生まれた時に私たちの足にバリューのたから例えばとらわれていません
は
それらは人生を通じて発見します
やりたいことを行って諮問してください
なぜあなたはそれが好きですか
どう感じますか
私とあなたは
同じ趣味を強要するかもしれません
そこには様々なユーザーに
コミュニケーション型入試であるプレス tv の教える
それらを発見する簡単なくてきてがあります
やってみましょう
旅とペンを用意してください
やり好きなことを3つ書いてが
それぞれのあるのにそれを愛する
一の理由を入れています
例えば私の場合は
さあ
同社
旅行
それぞれは yg を生き税
今日は時間はまだないん
サーフィンだけピックアップして
紹介します
これがファンを拝するいうです
このアクティビティから
大切にしている言葉を発見します
それはー
挑戦
cf
これらのアクティビティーかなぁ
あなたの解説にしている言葉を見つけることでございます
はい
それはー
価値を発見する品となります
何があなたを使用せ
あなたを幸せになります
あなたの小さなコマは周り作ります
では
さあ
大きなコマに
成長させていく
どうされますか
それは
子猫次はバンッ
あなたの拡張の
場所
友人家族コミュニティの方をする
ということですね
留学から日本に戻る
日中はインターンシップ
よれば e ショップ
バーン
bar haze 影響何も車
b 4浅村とだ
ドームにを減らすそういうことでん
これは人だったら最悪だったん
パワーまあまあ苦労することになります
ただラッキーあっ
インターンシップ先の社員として働くことになったんです
ワークは不死いたします
たらしい仕事をしようと意気込んでいた時です
入手が開きます
も一緒に働こうという言葉を信じ
なん
私のパーツだけ流お話になりません
私はなっ
個人の課長
説明しない組織に入ろうとしていたんです
個人の課長を大切にしない組織にあなたの時間とエネルギーを捧げる意味は何ですか
人生は有限です
あなたの端を
広げていかなければなりません
あなたの価値に声
友人家族コミュニティの価値を理解し
つなげることでさらに多くの人たちを巻き込んでいくことができるのです
今私に素敵な家族がいるのは私が自分を発見
今の対処方
お互いの価値を尊重したかみ合っています
ここで大切なことを言います
それは
お互いの価値を
指定しないことです
1案がそれぞれ
違った価値観ん
多くの人たちが自分たちよりない
相性なこういう増え使われているパートナーを見つけることがこんなん
他の活動
友人家族コミュニティの価値をつなげることでさらに多くの人たちを巻き込み
さらに
多くの人たちを幸せにしていくことができるんですね
ではいっ
大きな玉にしていくためには
どうしたらいいと思いますか
それは
コネクティがそのシャレならん
た超
社会問題とつなげることです
私たちが生きていく社会のやるべきことがたくさん
解決したい課題は何
日本は
少子高齢化を迎えています
生産人口は
印象しておる
生産性を語ってくれ
テクノロジーが白点は
必要不可欠です
2030年
80万人目治療
私はその問題に取り組んでいます
インドは健康が増加薔薇
it エンジニアが93
反映しがいない
インドはヴァンガード部エリアだけで
200万円の a 1に上がって
私は日本とインドう
なることでん
海問題に焦点はせたことで
想定もしなかった人たちを学校のようなことができ
駅間
大手企業
片廊下と入力車
彼らが
私たちの取り組みにし
何でしょ
問題がつながることで
ものはさらに勢いを増して回っていきます
そして
多くの人たちはがっこいい
多くの人たちを幸せにしていることができるんです
んでしょ
発見することから駒は成長し始めます
誰もが最初から大きな鎌を持っているわけではないんです
このまま成長させていくことができます
以下針は悪
あなたのたちを発見
これにと呼ばれるん
あなたの価値をつなげて
connect いうソーシャルバルあなたの価値を社会問題をつなげる
駒田大きくなればなるほどチップがずっ
巻き込まれる人たちも増えてくるんです
駒をを寄付していく過程は必ずしも真っ直ぐな道ではありません
好んだりな割れたりし
2ため立ち上がって前に進んでいきます
そして誰もが軸を作ることができるんです
この質問が最初のあなたたち
何があなたを知らせしますか
ありがとうございました
ます